[Applause]
good morning [__] uncle Joey
beautiful better be alive Thursday
December 8th you got the world by the
balls and they got an IOU you understand
me
podcasts tonight 6 o'clock and around
little things going on today but the
most important thing of the day it's
something I got put together because of
you [__] my special it's on
seeso TV you can't get it in Canada or
the UK yet we're making some [__]
call from corners and satellites the
first off I want to appreciate all the
love and support from you guys for this
special over the years you know I love
you [__] this is above beyond
so thank you very much you know I worked
hard for it 25 [__] years banging out
with these [__] savages never sold my
soul do it out of [__] I'd do it so uh
that's it that's what we're [__] doing
today you understand me but as far as
you guys concerned the rest is up to you
the way it was up to me 20 years ago I
keep being a [__] but what do
something with my life you got the world
by the balls today is that they start
still he is a [__] about Christmas no he
is the [__] that [__] don't stress
[Music]
stress on you okay little [__] bumps
it's been almost a month since the
[__] election oh it is a month and
you people are still trumping it up
listen it's over it's over move on with
your [__] life in a good way it's
been a month and you keep talking about
Trump and what's gonna happen by now you
can have a relationship you put on a job
you could have spawned the child you're
gonna smoke 20 ounces but you're still
stuck on Trump and how bad is listen
move the [__] out you still got a job
you still all and you still gotta get up
every morning and subjective work that's
all that matters
leave Trump along I don't listen what on
the end do you think I'm sitting here
trauma that who gives a [__] it's over
move on you're sitting there waiting for
a recount are you [__] serious shits
moving
and you wait for a [__] recount
listen stab yourself in the [__]
eyeball move on with your life who gives
a [__]
move on that's it it's over every day I
wake up oh oh chubby there's women and
it'll walk across it like that's gonna
do it ain't no to dick he's still gonna
be count when he's on your FAFSA who
gives a [__] you [__] my firm is too
[__] sensitive what's gonna happen
who gives a [__]
worried about your [__] life you
think I give a [__] about all these
outside dick Boak you got a wife you got
a kid and you got bills and you sit
Network the [__] keep doing what you've
been doing kick it up a [__] notch
and stop your [__] whining it's
Thursday November [__] December
[__] 8:00 and you're still talking
about what happened a month ago and you
see nobody left nobody's gone nobody
left where is everybody was going to
Spain and [__] bro don't say anything
just to get [__] attention Eddie
he'll have a party open if he wins I'll
go oh well here's so valiant you know so
they cap at themselves in the back go
[__] yourself meanwhile we're here
smoking reefer like I'm [__]
with three hands when we stand up oh
[__] with the present [__] the assistant
president [__] the principal [__] a ball
look what we are today okay where's the
print what's the school principal wet
all the [__] answers and the guy
who's counting it all suck your dick so
do me a favor go to sea so calm right
now name email and then this one asks
for a coat pressing Joey I'm asking me
as a brother help me out
so we've got another special me just
keep [__] working [__] all
right I'm with you you're with me and
they want to be with a shout-out back to
the [__] UK my apologies on the C so
special not coming through but I'm gonna
make it up to you [__] all
right we're good should we smoke another
boat I mean we're here look we're with
the [__] under you gotta go back in
and talk to your [__] boss about one
who gets a [__] it's tears they tell
them on a suck your dick you mean
business you put on your gamer through
[__] your Game of Thrones soup you
get the sword you stab [__]
one more what the front I don't know
where to go at least let's hang together
yeah we'll pick up a [__] pick up a
[__] nugget of debt that kind of clock
me [__] around tonight yeah Louis
gomez tonight my main little Puerto
Rican Italian from New York I love that
[__] we're gonna blow up I'm
gonna have a doctor on [__] the
podcast event in case somebody goes
deeper than
[Music]
all right like I should be do I love you
[__] we're all my lawyer I
thought I'm with this eye or you may
think of my mom and I'll be in the house
or you see them I didn't get you bother
[__] and do but besides that I love
you [__] see you tonight six
o'clock again thank you for all the love
with the special the support man you
guys are my [__] world without you I
have baked thank you [__] see
you later 6 p.m.